social distancing doesn't its reborn not
even the coronavirus can stop Camila
Kibeho and Shawn Mendes from putting
their love on full display the two have
been quarantined together in Miami and
on Thursday they were spotted on a
little lover stroll holding hands and
sipping coffee and over the weekend
Shawn Mila were snapped enjoying a brief
break outside soaking in some vitamin D
and fresh air
yep that's a shirtless Shawn with his
arm fully wrapped around Camila hand on
face coffee in hand mid makeout we are
going to sing a few songs today because
social distancing doesn't have to be
boring no it doesn't the PDA filled
outings come after the lovebirds
performed a live concert on Instagram
this is a crazy time and we're all gonna
come out of this together
we're gonna pull through and we're gonna
try and connect and make each other
smile in the meantime and so that's what
this is for
so we will go flat and sharp yes and we
will miss a couple we will entertain you
but we can't say it's gonna be won't hey
it sounds pretty damn good to us
[Music]
funny
and that right there
that's the look of love folks and as if
that wasn't cute enough on Wednesday
Camila shared this pic to her insta
story she's teaching Shawn Spanish and
Shawn is teaching her to play the guitar
[Music]
on Tuesday the Havana singer announced
that her upcoming romance tour has been
postponed writing on Instagram in part
quote we can't start rehearsals without
putting people at risk and with so much
up in the air with no real definitive
end in sight I feel this is the
responsible thing to do she concluded
her message urging fans to be gentle and
loving and kind to yourself last week
Shawn shared a similar message on
Instagram encouraging fans to take care
of themselves hey guys just want to say
hello I'm sending all of my love up to
every single one of you please take care
of each other and take care of
yourselves I love you so much he also
announced that the Shawn Mendes
foundation would be aiding coronavirus
relief efforts again I just want to say
be patient with yourself please do
because it's it's just craziness and
yeah give yourself the patience and love
that you deserve right now yep and as
human beings we're really coming
together I think so
we really are yeah that's the only and
that's the only way we get through these
kinds of things is together not together
[Music]